liebe macht blind das könnte in diesem
fall wirklich zutreffen denn vor dem
landgericht ingolstadt muss sich heute
eine moldawische prostituierte
verantworten die ihrem freier über die
jahre 300.000 euro abgezockt haben soll
der freie hatte sich in sie verliebt und
das hat die dame dann scheinbar schamlos
ausgenutzt und jörg völkerling der es
ist für uns in ingolstadt
der prozess heute der war sehr kurz
warum das weil es schon mal einen
durchlauf gegeben hat im vergangenen
dezember verurteilte das schöffengericht
ingolstadt die dame wegen besonders
schweren betrugs zu drei jahren und drei
monaten haft
das war dem staatsanwalt aber zu wenig
und der angeklagten zu viel
deswegen kam es heute zur neuauflage es
hätte zwei tage lang verhandelt werden
sollen auch das opfer ein 51 jähriger
computer fachmann aus der region
ingolstadt sollte gehört werden aber vor
der verhandlung entschloss sich die
bulgarische prostituierte ihr
verteidigungsverhalten zu ändern sie
wolle jetzt hintermänner nennen sie
wolle ihre schuld eingestehen und
daraufhin hat der vorsitzende richter
konrad kliegl ihr letztlich nachdem sie
gestanden hat einen strafrabatt von drei
monaten gewährt er hat dabei neben dem
geständnis natürlich auch die besondere
blauäugigkeit des opfers mit in seinem
urteil erwähnt 300.000 euro das gerade
gesagt blauäugigkeit wie funktioniert
das
der geschädigte lernte die bulgarische
prostituierte die hier in ingolstadt
unter den namen alicia im club venus
anschaffte im februar 2017 kennen und
führte wohl nach seinem dafürhalten eine
zehnmonatige liebesbeziehung mit ihr
dieser klub wird über der bar mit dem
spruch venusfalle für sich und das wurde
wohl tatsächlich zur venusfalle für den
mann der ihr in den zehn monaten 200.000
euro für ihre liebesdienste mit gab
letztlich versprach sie ihm dann eine
rendite von 7 bzw 21.000 euro im jahr
wenn er nachts mit ihr auf einen saturn
auf den parkplatz des alten stadions in
ingolstadt fährt und einem russen dort
dieses geld übergibt 300.000 das gab er
den mann ohne quittung und danach war er
weg und zwei tage später war auch die
frau weg
und das geld ist bis heute nicht wieder
aufgetaucht ich habe ihnen danach
gefragt den geschädigten ob er was von
diesem geld wieder gesehen habe er hat
nur den kopf geschüttelt und ist
weggelaufen und wie geht es jetzt mit
der täterin weiter die frau ist nicht
umgebildet sie hat in moldawien sogar
studiert sie war der zollbeamten und sie
hat heute ganz bitterlich während die
ganzen beweisaufnahme geweint sie
fürchtet zu recht auch das in moldawien
bekannt wird womit sie in deutschland
geld verdient hat sie sitzt jetzt schon
seit einem jahr in u-haft in der
frauenabteilung der jva stadelheim sie
hat in moldawien eine 16-jährige tochter
im knast hat sie niemand mit dem sie
reden kann jemand der sie versteht auch
das hat der richter ihn natürlich zugute
gehalten als erschwerungsgründen für sie
und ihr in aussicht gestellt dass sie
nach der hälfte der haftstrafe wieder in
ihr heimatland abgeschoben werden könnte
dankeschön jörg völkerling aus
ingolstadt